in 1997 JK Rowling published Harry
Potter and the Philosopher's Stone but
most of our audience didn't actually
read that book they read Harry Potter
and the Sorcerer's Stone or a hippo Sir
Alec old associate Harry Potter has
Sanga jadoo Harry Potter la Piedra
Filosa
[Music]
the bewitching Harry Potter books have
reached readers in over 200 territories
in over 60 languages the authorized
translations came from separate
publishing houses with little oversight
from the author so translators were not
only tasked with adapting the text from
English into their target languages and
cultures but also making assumptions
about Rowling's intentions and
translating the spirit of her approach
their task was particularly challenging
because the Harry Potter series is
filled with invented words alliteration
wordplay and British cultural references
the main characters for his name's Harry
Hermione and Ron mostly stayed the same
across languages with small changes to
accommodate different alphabets and
phonetics that's easy enough for
conventional names like Harry Potter but
many of the other proper names in the
books carry loaded meanings meanings
that would be lost if it's not
translated take Severus Snape the name
invokes severity and sounds like snake
so the Italian translator made the jump
in named him celeries Python which is
basically Python in French she's seven
whoop
which means sufferest arrogance as you
can tell both solutions sacrifice
Rowling's alliteration the name Hogwarts
combines two English words but because
the name stayed the same in most
languages those connotations were lost
for those readers and an attempt to
preserve Rowan's approach to the
school's name the French translator used
bula bula means license bacon or fat the
Hungarian version went with Oxford a mix
of the British University Oxford and
walk foot oh hell no blue cheese the
house names and founders also
experienced unique changes in some of
the target languages in Catalan the
names became Nikken or Gryffindor
serpentine Slytherin Mary Powell
ravenclaw and or tendency a Hufflepuff
there is a ton of wordplay that happens
to my Harry Potter books as well the
famous Diagon Alley a play on the word
diagonally and the infamous Knockturn
alley from nocturnally this type of pun
is a real puzzle for translators
and most drop get in favor of literal
translations the Spanish translator was
able to Elise rhyme with callejón Diegan
and translators had several approaches
to Quidditch an invented game made from
the invented words waffle bludger and
snitch the three types of balls used in
the game in Spanish the words were not
changed the French translator kept the
word Quidditch but changed the names of
the balls and others change the game's
name altogether and Dutch footage is
simple in Norwegian is crumpled don't
house a new standardized test in the
Wizarding World were always able to
retain their animal acronyms but in
Swedish they're implied meanings for me
while the wording was changed owls
became room examining a throw comstor
yet
meaning goat in Swedish and needs were
changed to rook 10 svet which Mukunda
throw pastas or foot drive from bluetick
meaning measly or mean the infamous
anagram of Tom Marvolo riddle name was
altered by many translators to achieve
the same revelation of I am Lord
Voldemort in Danish Thomas named Romeo
gay day Lu Yuna and in French he's Tom
Elvis judicial which was extra clever
because judicial means eight riddle
culturally the Harry Potter series is
unmistakably British but translating
that for a global group of readers
wasn't easy some food items were changed
to make them seem less foreign to the
target country sherbet lemons a popular
candy item in Britain became krembo a
chocolate-covered sweet from Israel
crisp became chips in the US and in the
Arabic version bacon became eggs
sometimes a foreign setting undergoes
translation to for the Ukrainian
translation the atmosphere of an English
boarding school was swapped out for an
orphanage
in the books and films Hagrid has a
provincial West country accent no bloody
Harry didn't you ever wonder where your
mum and dad learned oh you're a wizard
Harry for the Japanese translations it
was replicated by using Tohoku dialect
which is a pastoral accent from
northeastern Japan other translators
chose to have Hagrid simply speak more
informally while others dropped his
accent entirely
despite translators best efforts to
remain true to the text some things were
still lost in translation and the
mainland Chinese editions of Harry
Potter
there were footnotes to explain puns and
cultural references the Spanish
translators sometimes used italics to
signal an invented word with no
translation but in the end it doesn't
matter if you're reading Harry Potter
and the Philosopher's Stone or the many
translations of it one thing that always
seems to translate is the love fans
around the world share four tales of a
boy who lived
you
[Music]